after three days of parliamentary debate
in strasbourg the joint assembly
european union africa caribbean pacific
ends
the opportunity to question its co-president
the belgian louis michel on the progress
made thanks to this partnership but
also to establish the list of what he  remains
to be done
mr louis michel hello hello
you have been minister of foreign affairs
you have been commissioner for
development and humanitarian affairs
you know the
democratic republic of the congo well
you know africa in
general tell us in view of this
experience
what  is your your feeling do
you think that
europe's vision of africa has changed it has
evolved but it has evolved really too
slowly for my taste what for
decades we were a bit of a prisoner of
our bad conscience with  of the
former colonizing countries and which
developed development strategies
which were above all of
a charitable nature  that
is to say that the independents
basically I have always pleaded for us to
get out of this relationship of dependence
between the donor and the beneficiary
today little by little the relationship is
becoming much more balanced we are
becoming  partners more than
donors and has benefited
me I have always pleaded for our
development policies to be able to
strengthen the states much more and
strengthen the states in their
impartiality to ensure, for example,
that for a citizen in an African country
there is access  equal to justice
to administration to health
to education is also to culture
which is a parameter not to forget
far too often when we do
development and therefore all that advances
mentalities change but very slowly
precisely if today  hey we still have
meetings between European parliamentarians
and parliamentarians from these
countries it's good that there are still
needs
I very honestly think that
the assembly  the joint parliamentarian has had
a fairly exceptional educational effect in terms of
democracy
today we have encouraged we have trained
this parliamentarian to be relevant and
impertinent even if that were to
disappear
there would clearly be a lack in
our relations and in the
concrete policies carried out  in the name of this
partnership of this relationship, but
basically we only have the capacity
of a megaphone,
we exert pressure, we advocate
resolutions, I remind you that
official development assistance
still largely remains the responsibility of
European states
in a few words
could you explain to us the conclusions of
these three days of meeting will take
a resolution later on concerning hugo there
who will launch an extremely
vigorous appeal will strengthen the means and also
to work on
scientific and medical research
because  that the pharmaceutical industries
have not been very quick to engage
proactively in  ns research
that's for ebola we're going to talk
today about terrorism it's
essential as a subject africa
today is traveled you know
the Islamic state boko haram aqmi
sir all that are
terrorist groups y  who engage
in absolutely abominable abuses and
well it's not just an African question
it's a global European European African question
we know very well that African states
do not have the means to fight
effectively against the emergence of these
movements  and white, we have to
help them at the intelligence level so
that we probably also have them at the level
of
military resources police resources that's not all
and also at the social level
you mentioned it quickly at the beginning
of  interview the economic aspect of
economic development for these countries
there we saw the 15th summit of the
Francophonie which has just ended in
Dakar the French-speaking countries
today have a real economic weight
with  a modus vivendi
based on collaboration with the
former colonial powers should this
relationship with cpe tend towards this
example of the Francophonie I think
that development cannot
take place if there is no economic development
it is  for example that 1%
growth in africa is 1%
300 without more well that represents
almost 2 times the equivalent of all
official
development assistance africa has extraordinary potential
but to develop this potential we must
also  that there are states the
market economy is never virtuous if
there are not states of states for republics of
states to redistribute prosperity to
create it is a bit what is lacking
today what  will be the challenges in
the future for this cpe partnership
i think a first question that
will arise is what aspects
must remain in this format is what
the caribbean cannot leave with
the regional organization and the pacific
with lammer  and  st what we should not
have a great partnership africa
europe
i think that these are good
questions there is also an element is
that the aspects are busy
becoming aware and that is very good of their
political
weight their weight  policy that has
economic repercussions
they also want to consolidate their
relations with the countries of the south, that is to
say it is the famous south-south cooperation,
but it is obvious that to consolidate their
state, that is to say to create fashioned
to implement public institutions
binds to the service of people that sum seems
a priority all the same
and there there is still a young person helped a
lot of work to do it is to fight
against corruption
we too besides we must
continue to do it in our own
countries do not s  it's not about saying it happens
with you and not with us there are
examples quite regularly with us
too so this relationship must be much
more frank much more more open
much more i
finally irrelevant and that that here we have that it's
an enclosure where it happens and it
happens for the good of
Europeans space for the good of this country michel
thank you very much blurry